we don't take kimy with our hands okay
so as you're watching his movement I
don't take this in my hands my Center
has to move okay so let's look at the
Young aspects of his movement as he's
coming
in he goes
around and here's where the young aspect
first starts from here over second Young
aspect is
down okay got it you're going to go over
down all right and as he goes over down
I don't leave my Center still in space
and make my hands do that right so as he
is going in I go the other way with my
center
and I go down with my Center
move I heeld my center for his
Ste he move
under not
here my Center
[Music]
moves under
okay try that
again my body is
straight my elbows are straight my wrist
turn
cracki don't
paint
circles with your
body your
Joe out for
Target okay you're not doing
this you're doing
this
here
turn turn my wrist straight down or I
turn my
wrist
okay so watch you're
[Music]
crazy lean
here here all this
stuff Bo over done okay you see
that TR okay we'll go into a Toshi Zuki
now so it comes
around boom down
in so let's just introduce the basic PN
first in
okay let's just get that go having done
the general pattern we're going to work
on one thing at a time one is uh how do
I transition okay so follow the rules
where linear ends circular begins where
circular ends linear begins you have to
have a constant motion never ever do
reverse motion okay and then second L uh
the weapon and all weapons have to stay
between me and the opponent okay so as I
do this you can see that it's doing that
okay don't go like this one back reverse
see
that my my weapon is following the in
space boom
okay boom
incorrect keep the threat going there it
is
down going slow
[Applause]
not don't pay attention to the last part
yet this is the part right here boom
and getting away from this
[Music]
okay all
right okay so we're go
slow okay hit and we don't want the Joe
to go
defensive the Joe is going to keep
following her weapon around forcing her
to come off takes the angle
deviation and it catches it right there
okay keep that there there you go
again one so as it goes
Kitty Joe follows it around she has to
get off here we are right here catching
it there okay that's what we're doing
here all right
try watching my own people here there's
like it's so weird to them to do this
but I've always done it this way
okay what they want to do is
block okay first of all there's no
blocking if it if we're doing what looks
like a block it's because what type of
tempo or training are we doing EMB
embryonic which means this is not the
correct timing okay that's where we use
the opponent's
weapon as a vector a visible tactile
Vector marking the angle of attack where
we don't block
okay
so there that is why I don't have to end
up go pretend I don't have to end up in
this position I should have never ended
up in this
position what I'm doing
instead is protecting myself do you see
I'm protecting myself as I determine
where the hell is this weapon going
straight down low around mid I don't
freaking know okay so I put this weapon
in his face I know that he's starting to
shift so hence this foot goes there
immediately as he pulled off
connection and I start to see more
what's happening I regain connection
right
there to do
that my my weapon is doing
this boom watch the tip boom watch the
tip
here now my tip is
moving on the figure
eight we go
one B round
back
down you're you're this is going to feel
weird because you're like over here you
see and you want to be here in that
perfect
blockable
position that I am boom
boom
in again this is
onic
boom
in maybe over
here pay attention to the way that I
appear to twist but I move my body so I
untwist okay oh right here is Twisted
but I move my body and it's gone
okay try that quickly so we can get on
with it all right so we're going and
that's where you hit it in the actual
timing so just like on Mia Tosh it's
somewhere around here okay there's a lot
of difficulty in knowing is this Jon is
Chon or gon well not if I freaking stop
it at it Source got it
in the embryonic training though where
it appears that you're blocking you got
to be careful with this
technique that you're not going to ro
over rotate the
cross so this does not ever go back on
the other side of his
weapon that'll be too far to the actual
timing application timing so as you come
around
boom you have to stay here you go here
and you push down make sure you're not
bringing it around when you're doing
that I'm going boom boom down stop
in this will be the incorrect form back
boom now
[Music]
down
in we'll stay embryonic
today okay let's try all right so uh
going around all right so here we are in
the embryonic
level
and I want to
go straight into the
tush which is going to put the Power
hand here right hand and I drop the
cheek okay that's where I'm at the
problem with this
technique is
that the hand comes back up so what a
lot of people do will rewind the
film is they Short
change the power hand see it never went
down and they start to bring it up and
now you're on the other side of the a
you over rotated the cross you see that
now you're on the other side that
creates That
Swing again martially everything is in
the atos so you would never do this to
get your counting
coup you're you're here you drop that
and then you come in and spear him okay
you would do that in real life if your
life dependent on it you don't you're
not going to enter into
the advantage of the knife get closer
unless it's clear as day okay so you
have to get the tush but when we're
undisciplined our right hand doesn't
drop we go too fast we do it maybe a
little but and I got on the other side
of the Cross and it starts to bring it
this way that's what we're trying to
comeb about so it goes down finish then
it comes
in there is
no from this part here there is no angle
deflection that you are
seeking here you're doing the exact
opposite this comes
up to Target
level
there when you get more angle deflexion
you're going the wrong way now you come
up here no
so you go straight down in the embryonic
complete now this comes off the hill you
see and then you
injure so the caveats here we'll change
sides is complete Theos at the embryonic
level there it is right there second
caveat here is don't come here the tip
comes up with the
movement okay and at all cost while
you're doing those things is you're not
going to ever get on the other side and
over rotate the cross one more time that
doesn't happen it's just straight down
boom finish it bring the tip up and you
go okay try it again